I'm looking at all these mostly dead
Spartans and I'm wondering is speedo
Underpants at a cave really the wisest
battle gear there most of you may be
dead because you went out to or dress in
what a five-year-old wears to cosplay
Superman the oracles would stand as a
warning Lena Headey isn't seriously
Lannister in this narration sac Snider
did not direct this movie but he
co-wrote the screenplay I imagine he
wrote this thing in slow motion and the
movie just followed suit this one
beheading probably took up three pages
of the screenplay also let's just go
ahead and add a hundred sins for that
for Athens is a pile of stone and wood
and cloth and dust and human remains and
metal and earth and midi-chlorians this
is some of the most egregious and
unnecessary nudity I've seen since Logan
Persian King Darius annoyed by the
notion of Greek freedom has come to
Greece to bring us to heel I have no
clue what's going on
we started on Leonidas dead at the end
of the last movie then her speech about
him dying wherein she casually dropped
something about ten years but also
clearly seems to blame the Persian king
for that war that killed Leonidas now
where is this happening now ten years
went by and we're going to war again do
I have that right if you're gonna expose
it so much movie you could at least give
the viewer their bearings they attack
before they can establish their war camp
and supply their soldiers is this whole
movie gonna be our talking over
slow-motion footage back in those days
human blood looked like CGI strawberry
jelly agonizingly slow horse stampede no
matter how much of a badass you are or
want to appear to be taking off your
helmet is not a good idea especially
considering it just save your life about
four seconds ago
whatever you're a badass this guy turns
around and is so enamored with Xerxes he
probably looks at him for a good 10
seconds before turning back around to
see an arrow coming straight for
obviously since everything is in slow
motion this could be a second for all I
know but that's why it looks so dumb
when he gets hit by this thing guess I
won't be needing this anymore thank God
everyone in this battle just leaves this
dude alone so he's able to do this
no it was Darius his son Xerxes whose
eyes have the stink of Destiny about
them and the mystic leaves could see the
stink of destiny in his eyes all the way
from the beach it was so stinky
mystically is knew he should have killed
that boy
why didn't he was there some reason he
didn't other than to make this movie
happen her ferocity bested only by her
beauty her beauty matched only by her
devotion to her King so two things are
actually better than her ferocity that I
guess when the King is ailing they turn
the public throne room into a public
bedroom which seems awkward at best in
her he had the perfect warrior protege
that his son Xerxes would never be you
literally just spent the last scene
telling me that letting Xerxes live
would be the end of the mystic leaves
also are you telling me this guy
survived long enough after getting hit
by an arrow and sailing across the sea
back home also I guess they saw how tore
his armor off in such a way that the
arrows stayed lodged in his chest do you
make that happen
- no three pho father's stag don't
openly stand on an attacking Shore
breaking boat with zero shields or armor
basically right Artemisia gathered the
priests wizards and mystics from every
corner of the Empire they agreed that
they needed to strip this guy naked wrap
him in gauze dip him in ancient potions
have him walked the desert and maybe
just maybe he'd find a cave where he
could jump into an evil pool and turn
into a god how a bunch of holy man
magicians and shamans from around the
world agreed on this is more of a
miracle than this guy turning into a god
and as he emerged no part of a human man
that was as he survived also while in
this pool he was given all sorts of
jewelry to wear because that's what evil
God transforming pools do he was
stripped cleansed glabrous and smooth
elaborate glabrous sure I google that
but you just pulled a vocab word from
God's butthole to try and sound smart
when you casually tossed it among a
series of blue-collar words do movie
narrator producer and Bob Xerxes was
reborn a god because he walked into a
pool this movie explains everything
except that you actually want to know
about God also he's undefeatable and
indestructible now right unless meses
stuff Lee's or whatever his name is does
the same thing the Greeks are doomed
right that's not how blood works so he's
a god but because she sort of caused it
she controls him what and as the god
King stood before his people God can
damn it why is she still talking in the
village of monster army over a million
strong whoa we skipped over a major
tail here how did cirque C's conjure up
monsters for an arm remember the battle
that began the story it was just a bunch
of dudes it's not like there were a
bunch of battle ready monsters all over
the place I imagined something like that
takes time money and more importantly
existing monsters this society clearly
hasn't established the group therapy
rules on the talking torch wait it's
what's for dinner
the shot that is supposed to be cool
only gives us more time to examine how
disappointed we are he's willing to die
now kingside this movie makes it seem
like dealios was the guy who recruited
the 300 to fight against the Persians
but I clearly remember some Scarface
dude who rounded up the man in the last
movie unless of course you and Leonidas
have already made a deal with Sexy's
what is happening is this movie 20-plus
minutes of prequel before or at some
point going modern this is what
wikipedia says it is a follow-up to the
2006 film 300 taking place before during
and after the main events of that film
because that makes sense I mean that the
first movie even acknowledged any of
this is no typical Greek city-state this
is sparta this movie strokes sparta so
much I'm surprised the Mediterranean Sea
didn't get pregnant we are not
interested in United Greece that is your
dream for mystically is not ours all I
am concerned with is the preservation of
Sparta she doesn't even know what the
Oracle is going to say yet and she turns
this guy down
this movie does nothing to explain why
Sparta hates Athens so much they're
unwilling to join forces now yes this is
revisionist history so that the romantic
notion of three hundred men fighting
millions of Persians on their own can
happen but the reasons for this
revisionist history are unsatisfactory
it's funny that you mock freedom here in
a selfish oscillation funny or still
that you can say that with a straight
face
considering the fake ass CGI bull going
on behind you I don't know the Persians
have often despot is something that
cannot refuse and what is that I'm sorry
but this whole Spartan men want to die a
beautiful death thing is completely
overrated it's doubtful that even the
Sparta is shown in these movies puts a
beautiful death over basic in common
sense
the director said let's have your
character eat an apple with a knife
it'll make you seem like even more of an
asshole you know asshole area aside this
is a really inconvenient way to eat an
apple I guess this guy fell on some sort
of glass ceiling well better to be a
dead man above a glass ceiling than a
living woman underneath it that's what I
always say the Kappa kissing also just
in case you didn't know the Eva Green
character was the worst of the worst
here's this scene I guess the next scene
is her in bed with the head and getting
angry that he never listens to her he
completely ignores the Mythbusters
findings on projectile shot through
water cliche 300 sequel prequel whatever
takes a page from the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise for better or worse
to his found near death by Persian
emissary obviously it was someone we
know from the previous movie guy that
got kicked down a hole he was much more
than that she was fed clothed and
trained by the finest warriors of the
Persian Empire you know by the guy he
was so good at fighting they sent him as
a messenger in the first movie so he
could die like a little bitch why would
she stop here
she just sliced open his leg and
probably his femoral artery as well
killing him in the process but now she
stopped short did she forget until now
that this guy saved her life and that
this is a training session
why does so many shots in this movie
have hovering white particles in the
Gerard Butler only appears in this movie
via shots from the first movie
he's not even credited he probably got
job like Crispin Glover on Back to the
Future 2 Oh Fassbender also got job here
like James Franco and dawn of the Planet
of the Apes to attack a force of over a
thousand ships with our mika force is
suicide such is my plan a plan which you
should all know since I told you we're
sticking with the plan which suggests
we've already planned this out and you
should know what's coming on even though
for some reason you don't seem to know
it how is it impossible this asshole is
just now sharpening his blade Jesus the
battle is minutes away asshole brothers
Bor it's been but five minutes since the
last rousing speech in this movie and by
God we will corner the market on rousing
speeches also no one on any of the other
boats besides this one is being inspired
right now why are all these soldiers
shirtless in these movies they wear
helmets but somehow haven't evolved to
understand torsos are important to
protect - hey dick face I'm sure he's
about to tell you I mean did they really
need to get this guy on line here they
went out on the sea to do battle but
ended up in this three circle
configuration and I'm no naval general
but this looks like a very goofy and
ineffective battle formation how is this
king two hundred foot tall wave aiding
the Persian Navy's attack not also a
tsunami the entire conquered world
should be worried about right now this
is some interstellar gear that wave is
easily five Persian boat lengths tall
this way
should decimate all the mediterranean
civilizations completely how are they
supposed to attack the ships are still
separate and far apart and your dudes
have swords not arrows so is this
command supposed to get them to jump in
the water and start swinging or what
this guy throws a spear but are the
persons even shooting arrows right now
yeah we've seen a couple but they aren't
exactly peppering the Greeks with I mean
look at these assholes what are they
doing I know that this ship got the
order to RAM the Persian ship but how
did the other ship on the other side get
this order I know they have these
flag-waving guys but how do you
communicate your order so quickly when
your view is blocked I love how that
massive interstellar wave just
disappears and is never spoken of again
after this battle starts by the way
while the Greeks do all this ramming
where is the rest of the gigantic
Persian fleet this is the problem with
action scenes like this no sense of the
overall battle where everyone is or what
people plan to do it's all noise and
blood movie suggests these two can see
each other I'm bored with your failures
been doubting that's apparently the name
Zack Snyder now goes by according to my
brain no a group of untrained men will
do so well against such a considerable
adversity whoa wait a minute these
assholes were untrained and yet they
pulled off every single maneuver without
a hitch
how long do you think we can hold them
I'll go on account of your chiseled abs
in this shot and say 12 hours that
doesn't happen I mean ours he's rumored
to have loosed the arrow that felled the
Great King Darius himself
so let's rehash that scene for people
who suffer from memento in these men
what a shrill character that created for
Eva green she's as one-dimensional as it
gets untrusting that the audience will
know how evil and unreasonable she is
now she expects results from thin air
which makes her stupid and not the type
of villain that's gonna be satisfying to
watched on this or hitting the water
feels like stock footage and maybe it is
but I'm guessing it's not but that this
films issues sent her mostly on an over
importance on the visual presentation
and an under importance on the story and
characters Wow
sure was lucky that when the Greeks came
out to battle today they had this fog to
work with what would the plan have been
if there was no fog or did they plan for
the fall the Greeks are retreating he's
got him right where he wants him
Shani is a fine tactician I was speaking
of statistically
yes you see being a terrible person
means I am excellent at the pronoun game
I refused to believe even in these
ancient times that both societies didn't
have detailed maps of the waterways this
surprise motherfucka moment is some
bullshit Jesus Christ how is this
happening
visibility aside the sea and the land
shouldn't be a mystery to any of these
people at this point gotta say I'm not a
fan of this jumping off the cliff onto a
boat to fight technique how many people
are gonna get injured or die trying this
also let's not forget but a lot of these
guys are untrained men like these
assholes suddenly have the bravery to
jump from this height and just start
whooping ass well won't be needing this
anymore
as you expected this battle scene is
chopped up all to hell God people be
spitting blood in this movie like
there's no tomorrow and every single
wound spurts blood at the camera to pay
off that 3d release I guess who puts a
throne on a goddamn warship especially a
throne this heavy and ornate what are
you doing here perfect time for this
conversation dad we just saw this guy
slice through asshole after asshole but
I guess because the mystic leaves is
awesome
he gets away with a simple kick and
instantly starts winning is so much cos
perfect score bro still telling the
story to the Spartans that's still a
thing does she also include all the
dialogue from Artemisia how does she
know all that and other rejected lines
from Braveheart holy what is up with
that moon why isn't the sea going
absolutely back crazy right now is it
about to collide with the earth I mean
Jesus Christ that moon is annoying
enough I'm gonna add another sin for it
that moon the mr. clay gives another
speech only ten percent of his army can
hear so begins many many chances for
Artemisia to just dispose of
Themistocles right now the character
we've been presented gives zero so why
she decides to let him live is amazingly
stupid the mr. Cleese agrees to a
late-night boat meeting with the Persian
Queen and goes without bodyguards and
somehow he's not killed immediately I'll
feel you the chance to avoid such misery
and join Artemisia gives us the good old
college try but seriously killing this
dude right now is the best thing
possible this part of the movie takes up
a good eight minutes of runtime and
makes no sense whatsoever
so the mystically is an Artemisia have
some weird sex which considering the Eva
Green factor is both awesome and
predictable after watching the dreamers
and dark shadows I think it's in her
contract to do uncomfortable sex scenes
these mask guard guys would be amazing
at cinema since Jesus Christ the sex
scene has been going on for over a full
minute we got it join no I would have
removed 50 sins if he said yes you know
why why it's pretty obvious that
Artemisia thinks this dude is the reason
why the Greeks are winning and she's
super evil so why the mercy now why
would she give us hey guys just want to
let you know if Berta means you don't
worry I'm still on your side so let us
commence with the singing of summer
nights from Greece no not Greece but
Greece I'll explain later
and then some the we face huh it's
somehow going to mean more hell than she
has brought before don't ask me why she
didn't bring it in the last two battles
we could also look out with the
hurricane that only attacks her ships
but I asked the fall from the last
battle and he said it's not likely
since when did you assholes get archers
in the first battle you all threw Spears
you didn't think archers might be handy
okay this dude spear is one of the
Persians with all the oil on his armor
that Artemisia is going to set ablaze
with arrows later but this is one dude
there are about 10 to 15 dudes in the
water who all reach the boat so where
the fuck did they go there's no one
other than sylia's here so why haven't
the oil dudes overtaking this boat oh
yeah I remember that flashback of her
training she's a badass even though
she's yet to do anything present-day
that's demonstrated that the mystically
survives this Loch Ness monster of sorts
ex machina what the fuck Perry Oh
multiple sea beasts and they're fighting
each other just like what's happening up
top remind me again how this makes sense
or ties in or is important all how many
men would have been saved if the mystic
Lee's had killed that boy it sounds like
to me that it doesn't matter if he
killed that board the story so far is
that Artemisia is the true evil in the
story and she would have found a way to
manipulate a whole bunch of people to
start this war anyway also this guy got
hit by three goddamn arrows and was then
slung into the sea during a major
explosion how is he even the slightest
bit alive I guess this is after the end
of the first movie but I'm honestly not
sure the sequel is jump time period so
damn much I don't care anymore and this
is just some CGI be two bodies I don't
connect with it all let my army witness
two great warriors of Sparta of course
it's time for another speech by the way
I can't believe this is based on an
unpublished Frank Miller graphic novel
called Xerxes because it's clearly
Artemisia of the movie the Unitas was
betrayed by a hunchback tumbles
buttons have been sorted also he killed
like a million Persians but that's not
important to the story and his v2 queen
warning athenian you may not receive a
warm welcome
thank you very much character from the
last movie who was pointless in this
movie have I not given enough for your
dream of a united Greece um she given
like anything the last time these two
met all she did was tell him to go fuck
yourself essentially so the answer is no
then have I not given enough for your
ambitions Themistocles sorry to send
this again but no is there seem missing
where she gave him something
Themistocles is dead
these are lies I have seen it myself
absolutely no burns despite being
engulfed in flames can you believe that
you failed a soul this is your fault sir
mr. Glee's you are alright I'm conceding
this so that I can provide you all with
a fantastic speech have you guys ever
heard one of my speeches I take your
immediate non-answer as a no so here
goes a story that would be told for a
thousand years will tell this story for
a thousand years or else the rites go
back to marble somehow without autumn
uses commands the Persian Navy use
nothing essentially this mission is
going to be like finding the alien queen
killing her and ending the war by
default one thing that's been bothering
me after Leonidas destroyed a million
billion Persians and Themistocles
destroyed another large group of ships
how the Persian still have this many
boats and men today I want to feel
Themistocles throat beneath my boots
isn't a little bit greedy
you've already felt his penis in your
vagina who decides their spinal column
needs armor who says yes my lower lumbar
must be protected by gold encrusted
spiky things got a question who decides
how the battle will start this is like
the fourth open sea battle in this movie
and I can't figure out how anyone
decides how the attack will occur like
in this case why did the Persians even
allow the boat to make it this far
why aren't archers unleashing a million
arrows in their direction nobody goes
out of its way to make the finale
confusing and I have no idea who's doing
what here but I guess yay like how
aren't all the people who deliver the
splatter and kill shot not covered in
blood in this movie good luck steering a
horse through boat wreckage and dude I
mean you must have booked this horse
through some serious immersion therapy
to achieve this kind of bravery riding a
horse across fiery ship debris to face
your enemy feels like a video game
ending
this horse it's magic and I won't be
needing this anymore
movie rips off the both of them have the
other by the neck cliche from a dozen
previous movies I would rather die a
free man and his life can you just kill
her already it begins as a whisper sure
while these two were at each other's
throats there's definitely time for
another speech a wind my brother's of
sacrifice dan that was a long-ass story
she just told these dudes on this boat
you know a handful these guys are like
geez did we even need to hear about
Artemisia Themistocles having sex that
one time god damn does perch I have a
Commodore 64 where they run a simple
program that spits out random soldiers
ad infinitum I don't doubt for one
minute that Gorgo is a badass but two
women ever train in the Sparta we've
been shown isn't this a man's world
remember in 300 she tells the messenger
that women are tough because they're the
only ones who could give birth to the
strong men of Sparta but I don't
remember her ever picking up a sword and
learning how to use it like she's the
second coming of Leonidas
glabrous the skipper has yet to put a
single crab on board I want you to know
I understand even though we're enemies
you and I I understand the furor that
drives you I was there that day once a
Gregor crossed all of his head
[Music]
it's a new world the future is gold
I've been it and both we shall be your
friend